This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. I once went to a small business and tech conference in San Francisco, and among all the people hobnobbing in hoodies or khakis, a man emerged in full military attire. Dark green uniform with ribbons on his chest and tiny pins all perfectly affixed. Crew cut whole nine yards. He was a marine lieutenant colonel and he was by far the most interesting person in the room. I was just glued to him. Anyway, as we parted ways, he handed me this coin like thing. I mean, it was bigger than a coin. It was about an inch and a half in diameter or neatly decorated with the icon of the lieutenant
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我曾经去旧金山参加过一个小型商业与科技会议，在那些穿着连帽衫或卡其裤、到处寒暄的人当中，出现了一位身穿全套军礼服的男士。深绿色制服，胸前挂着勋表，别着一丝不苟的微型徽章。板寸头，精气神十足。他是一位海军陆战队中校，可以说是全场最有趣的人。我的目光全被他吸引住了。总之，在我们分别时，他递给我一个类似硬币的东西。我是说，它比硬币还大。直径大约有一英寸半，上面整齐地装饰着这位中校所在部队的
colonel's unit. And heavier than anything I'd care to keep in my wallet. I felt incredibly honored, but I didn't know what it was or what the hell I was supposed to do with it. I also got a coin like thing. It was from a tour guide at the Pentagon. I asked him what it was and he was like, eh, it's just something we do. Producer Avery Truffleman. I told my housemate Ben about my coin and he was like oh yeah I have one of those. It was my grandfather's. It is. I woke Ben up before I came to work so we sound really sleepy. So his coin is from the 101st Airborne. It's got the 101st Airborne insignia and chose a couple of there.
徽标。而且比我愿意放在钱包里的任何东西都要重。我感到无比荣幸，但我不知道那是什么，也不知道我到底该拿它怎么办。我也得到了一个类似硬币的东西。那是五角大楼的一位导游给我的。我问他那是什么，他说，呃，这只是我们的常规做法。制作人埃弗里·特拉夫曼。我把硬币的事告诉了我的室友本，他说哦，对啊，我也有一个。那是我祖父的。没错。我在来上班前把本叫醒了，所以我们听起来真的很困。所以他的硬币来自第101空降师。上面有第101空降师的徽标，还展示了其中的几个
The places that they fought via NAM World War II. On the back it says Randevi with Destiny, which is their motto, their creed, I don't know. Did he ever tell you like about this? I actually never met him. This is the only thing that I have of his. Every night I figured out that these coins are called challenge coins. And they are coins, but they're not currency, and they're not quite metals. Challenge coins are something different. Everything that I say here today is my own personal opinion and does not necessarily reflect
他们在越南和二战中战斗过的地方。背面写着“命运的约会”（Rendezvous with Destiny），这是他们的座右铭、信条，我也不太清楚。他有没有跟你说过这个？我其实从没见过他。这是我留下的他唯一的遗物。每天晚上我发现这些硬币被称为挑战币（challenge coins）。它们确实是硬币，但不是流通货币，也不完全是奖章。挑战币是完全不同的东西。我今天在这里所说的一切都只是我个人的观点，并不一定反映
the position of the Marine Corps. Roger that. Carrie Fosher is not in the Marines. She's a cultural anthropologist at Marine Corps University. She's encountered challenge coins many times throughout her career. I would imagine that except for the brand new people coming in, everybody will know that they exist. The degree to which they are used varies a great deal.
海军陆战队的立场。明白。凯莉·福舍不在海军陆战队。她是海军陆战队大学的文化人类学家。在她的职业生涯中，她多次遇到过挑战币。我想象除了刚入伍的新兵之外，所有人都会知道它们的存在。它们的使用程度差异很大。
This can depend on which military branch you serve in and your rank, but it goes further than that. There are so many different uses, so many different kinds of things that the coins can symbolize, depending on the context in which you're looking at them or somebody is giving them. Kerry says that one of the meanings of the coins is made apparent in the act of giving or exchanging them. The coins are literal tokens of gratitude, of appreciation, or love, or sympathy. They are a powerful and tangible form of connection within an institution that is not known for
这取决于你服役于哪个军种以及你的军衔，但远不止于此。挑战币有那么多不同的用途，能象征那么多不同的事物，这取决于你观察它们时的背景，或者别人送它们时的情境。凯莉说，这些硬币的其中一层含义体现在赠送或交换它们的行为中。这些硬币是感激、欣赏、喜爱或同情的不折不扣的象征。在一个不以多愁善感著称的机构里，它们是一种强有力且有形的联系形式。
being very touchy-feely. It can be difficult in certain contexts to express emotion, especially if it's across the ranks. And I do think that the coins are used in that way, as a physical symbol of affection or gratitude. So across ranks, people might be given a coin for a job well done, because there are only so many ways to show appreciation within the military. You can't give a person a raise, you can't give them a promotion. ways to show appreciation within the military. But of course, as Avery and I learned, these coins are occasionally given out to civilians. Most of the time I would give a coin just to say thank you for helping me out. That's Chris McGraft.
在某些情况下，表达情感可能很困难，特别是跨越不同军衔时。而且我确实认为这些硬币就是以这种方式使用的，作为情感或感激的物理象征。因此，跨越军衔，人们可能会因为工作出色而获赠一枚硬币，因为军队里表达谢意的方式实在有限。你不能给一个人加薪，你不能给他晋升。在军队里表达谢意的方式。但当然，正如埃弗里和我所了解到的那样，这些硬币偶尔也会发给平民。大多数时候我送出一枚硬币只是为了说一声谢谢你帮了我。那是克里斯·麦格拉夫。
He's a chief petty officer in the Navy. And I collect and trade challenge coins. Chris says he gives coins out to co-workers, old friends, anyone who doesn't be solid. And for that reason, you end up finding these coins in places where you would not expect to find any connection to the military. You know like in the hands of Wimpy podcasters like us. And the coins are a way to establish relationships outside of the institution.
他是海军的一名高级士官。我收集并交易挑战币。克里斯说他把硬币送给同事、老朋友，任何靠得住的人。正因为如此，你最终会在那些你意想不到的地方发现这些硬币与军队有联系。你知道的，比如落在了像我们这样无能的播客制作者手里。这些硬币是建立体制外关系的一种方式。
When these coins get sent out, they're a physical reminder of both the fact that the military is there, but perhaps more importantly that it's not some faceless, monolithic structure sitting in the Pentagon. There are human beings involved and they are human beings who can develop a professional of personal relationship with somebody outside the military. When I received my coin from the Pentagon tour guide, he just kind of unceremoniously handed it to me. But within the military, when a sailor, a soldier, a pilot, or a marine gives a coin,
当这些硬币被送出时，它们是一个物质上的提醒：一方面提醒人们军队的存在，但或许更重要的是，提醒人们它不是五角大楼里某个冷酷无情、整齐划一的庞大机构。其中包含着活生生的人，他们是能够与军队以外的人建立专业或个人关系的有血有肉的人。当我收到五角大楼导游给我的硬币时，他只是随随便便地递给了我。但在军队内部，当水兵、士兵、飞行员或海军陆战队员赠送一枚硬币时，
they don't just hand it over. There's a traditional handshake. Of course there is. The handshake is used whenever someone is transferring one of the coins over, and essentially you have the coin sitting in the palm of your hand. And then, with the coin in your palm, you firmly grasp the hand of the person you want to give the coin to. And then you flip both your hands over so it ends up in their hand. Chris has an amazing collection of challenge coins.
他们不仅仅是把它递过去。这里有一个传统的握手仪式。当然有。每当有人转交其中一枚硬币时，就会用到这种握手方式，基本上是把硬币放在你的手掌心。然后，手里拿着硬币，紧紧握住你想赠送硬币之人的手。接着，你们把两只手同时翻转过来，硬币最终就落在了对方手里。克里斯拥有令人惊叹的挑战币收藏。
Some don't look like regular coins at all. I've got one here, shaped like an ninja star. I've got another one shaped like a crown. You know, this one is a, it's shaped like a cougar profile view, but the teeth are open and you can actually use it as a bottle opener. The bottle opener could actually be quite practical because in addition to being gifts and heirlooms and tokens of appreciation, challenge coins are used to play a drinking game and if you're in possession of a coin, you can be in on the game. Jordan Haynes, a veteran of the Air Force, plays like this. If I was at a bar, I would have the coin in my pocket, and if I felt, you know, emboldened, I would pull a coin out of my pocket, and I would, I would throw it down on the bar,
有些看起来一点也不像普通的硬币。我这里有一枚，形状像忍者飞镖。我还有另一枚，形状像王冠。你看，这一枚是，它的形状是一个美洲狮的侧面剪影，但嘴巴是张开的，你实际上可以把它当成开瓶器。这个开瓶器其实相当实用，因为除了作为礼物、传家宝和感激的象征之外，挑战币还被用来玩一种喝酒游戏，如果你拥有一枚硬币，你就可以参与这个游戏。空军退伍军人乔丹·海恩斯就是这样玩的。如果我在酒吧里，我会把硬币放在口袋里，如果我觉得，你知道的，胆子大起来了，我会从口袋里掏出一枚硬币，然后我把它，把它重重地拍在吧台上，
or I might tap it, and maybe haul her out, coin check! And all his buddies and crew members would take out their coins. We expect them to reply with their coin doing the same thing. So now you've got all this craziness going on, because people are slamming their coins down and yelling out coin check. Go in check! And they go down the line, and each person pulls out their coin.
或者我可能会敲击它，也许会大喊一声：“查验硬币！”他所有的死党和机组人员都会掏出他们的硬币。我们期望他们用同样的硬币行为作出回应。所以现在你会看到所有这些疯狂的场面，因为人们把他们的硬币重重地拍在桌上，大喊着“查验硬币！”查验硬币！然后他们逐个进行，每个人都掏出自己的硬币。
Hopefully what happens is somebody doesn't have their coin. And if they don't have their coin, then boom. The person without their coin buys everyone a drink. But the person who does the coin check is liable for round of drinks if everybody does have their coin. So starting the coin check is also a gamble. And not all of the branches of the military
通常情况下，可能会发生的情况是有人没有带硬币。如果他们没有带硬币，那么，轰。那个没带硬币的人得请大家喝酒。但是，发起查验硬币的人如果所有人都带了硬币，那他就要负责请大家喝一轮酒。所以发起查验硬币也是一场赌博。并非所有的军种
are into the drinking game. I will say that I have not seen Marines initiate that kind of game. They would certainly participate if somebody from another service did that. But those who play the game are in it to win it. Some have their coins on them. Always. That little useless coin pocket you have in your jeans,
都热衷于这种喝酒游戏。我要说的是，我没见海军陆战队员发起过这种游戏。如果其他军种的人这么做了，他们当然也会参与。但那些玩这个游戏的人都是为了赢到底。有些人身上随时带着他们的硬币。总是带着。你牛仔裤上那个没用的小硬币口袋，
I've actually found a use for it and it's for my challenge coin. You gotta be on your toes, you know what I mean? If you're in a shower, you know, take your coin with you. If you're out running, whatever you're doing, you can carry the coin with you. You could be coin right here in the studio. As far as the history of challenged coins, there's sort of an apocryphal story
我实际上为它找到了一个用途，那就是用来放我的挑战币。你得时刻保持警惕，明白我的意思吗？如果你在洗澡，你知道的，把你的硬币也带上。如果你出去跑步，无论你在做什么，你都可以随身带着这枚硬币。你甚至可以在录音室里进行硬币查验。至于挑战币的历史，有一种近似传奇的故事
that traces them back to World War I, when an American army officer supposedly had some special coins minted for his men. And then one of those men was captured by French soldiers who mistook him for a German, and then he used his coin to prove that he was an American. So the coins have also always been about identity. They do tell a story about how the or the organization wants to be perceived. What do they think are the most important things that they can communicate about themselves to an
追溯到第一次世界大战，当时一位美国陆军军官据说为他的手下铸造了一些特殊的硬币。然后其中一个人被法国士兵俘虏了，法国士兵误把他当成了德国人，接着他用这枚硬币证明了自己是个美国人。所以这些硬币其实一直都关乎身份认同。它们确实讲述了一个关于组织或机构希望如何被外界感知的故事。他们认为，以图形形式向外界传达关于他们自身的最重要的东西是什么？
outside audience in a graphic form. And since identity in the military has a lot to do with hierarchy, there is also a hierarchy with challenge coins. As you move up through the ranks, you know, the challenge coins become more essentially valuable because they're harder to get. It's harder to get a chief-enabled operations coin. It's even harder to get a secretary of the Navy coin.
由于军队中的身份认同很大程度上与等级制度有关，挑战币也存在着等级制度。随着你军阶的晋升，你知道的，挑战币本质上会变得更有价值，因为它们更难获得。获得一枚海军总士官长行动币很难。要获得一枚海军部长币就更难了。
It's incredibly hard to get a presidential coin. Yes, the president has a coin. There's a really lovely video of Obama giving his coin to a woman who lost her brother in Afghanistan. And the military isn't the only institution to use challenge coins, although they were the first. Now some police departments make coins and some fire departments. NASA gets coins minted. Sports teams have coins. Jimmy Buffett has a coin. Jimmy Buffett the singer yeah. That's Jordan Haines again. He's the one who told us about the drinking game. A lot of these performers you know if they're doing a USO tour
获得一枚总统币简直难如登天。是的，总统确实有一枚硬币。有一个非常感人的视频，奥巴马将他的硬币送给了一位在阿富汗失去兄弟的女性。军队并不是唯一使用挑战币的机构，尽管他们是鼻祖。现在有些警察局会制作硬币，一些消防局也会。美国宇航局会铸造硬币。运动队有硬币。吉米·巴菲特（Jimmy Buffett）有一枚硬币。歌手吉米·巴菲特，是的。那是乔丹·海恩斯。就是他给我们讲了喝酒游戏的事。许多这样的表演者，你知道的，如果他们正在进行USO（联合劳军组织）巡演，
they'll have their coin with them in return to whoever presents them a coin. In addition to being a collector of coins, Jordan is actually in the business of making coins. He's made over three million of them, including Jimmy Buffett's. I am the founder and CEO of CoinForce.com. CoinForce is one of the private men's that designs and manufactures challenge coins. I'm holding a coin that I brought with me to the studio,
他们会随身带着自己的硬币，并回赠给任何向他们赠送硬币的人。除了是一名硬币收藏家之外，乔丹实际上还从事硬币制造的生意。他已经制作了三多万枚硬币，包括吉米·巴菲特的硬币。我是 CoinForce.com 的创始人兼首席执行官。CoinForce 是一家设计和制造挑战币的私人铸币厂。我手里拿着一枚我带到录音室的硬币，
a diamond-shaped coin that we made for astronaut Lindgren. It's got his name on it, it's like just super awesome coin. My god, we do awesome work. You don't have to be a president or an astronaut or Jimmy Buffett. You too can have a coin. You can design your own and then just go online and order it. That's basically what the military does. Most of the time a unit gets together and talks about what they want on their own and then just go online and order it. That's basically what the military does. Most of the time a unit gets together and talks about what they want on their coin and then gathers the money for it themselves. So we're not using taxpayer dollars. It's all buy our own for our own. So we are fundraising
这是一枚我们为宇航员林格伦制作的菱形硬币。上面有他的名字，这真是一枚超级棒的硬币。天哪，我们做的工作太棒了。你不必成为总统、宇航员或吉米·巴菲特。你也可以拥有一枚硬币。你可以自己设计，然后直接上网订购。军队基本上也是这么做的。大多数时候，一个单位聚在一起讨论他们想在硬币上印什么，然后自己筹集资金。所以我们没有动用纳税人的钱。这一切都是自掏腰包，自给自足。所以我们在内部筹款，
internally or we're doing car washes. Because coins are not in the budget, there's no set procedure for making them and no rules, which means the design process is very informal. Nine times out of ten in the Navy, someone takes that sketch and they use clip art and put it into PowerPoint and then send it off to the manufacturer. PowerPoint, Microsoft, PowerPoint. PowerPoint is installed on every government computer and it's for us, it's free. And then Jordan at CoinFor, or whoever the manufacturer is,
或者我们去洗车筹款。因为硬币不在预算之内，所以没有既定的制作程序，也没有规则，这意味着设计过程非常非官方。在海军，十有八九会有人拿着那个草稿，使用剪贴画，把它放到 PowerPoint 里，然后发送给制造商。PowerPoint，微软的 PowerPoint。每台政府电脑上都安装了 PowerPoint，而且对我们来说，它是免费的。然后 CoinForce 的乔丹，或者无论是哪位制造商，
will take that mock-up and finish a final design on real professional grade software. A design studio does not use PowerPoint to design a challenge coin. Oh, that's a relief. The individual coins take on a whole new meaning when a bunch are displayed together. And a lot of military folks make elaborate displays
都会采用那个模型，用真正专业的软件完成最终设计。设计工作室可不会用 PowerPoint 来设计挑战币。哦，那可真让人松了一口气。当许多硬币一起展示时，单个硬币便被赋予了全新的含义。许多军人都制作了精美的展示架，
or even custom furniture to show off their collection. Of course, some displays are much simpler. In Clinton's presidential portrait, he's posing in front of his collection of challenge coins and they're in a simple wooden display. But these coin displays are not like a flashy show of achievement at all. It becomes less a display of look at me and more a display of a lot of long, quiet, hard work over the course of decades.
甚至定制家具来炫耀他们的收藏。当然，有些展示架要简单得多.在克林顿的总统官方肖像中，他正站在他的挑战币收藏前摆姿势，那些硬币放在一个简单的木制展示架里。但这些硬币展示一点也不像浮夸的成就炫耀。它变得不再是“看我”的炫耀，而更像是几十年间漫长、平静而艰苦工作的展示。
The coin show all the professional and personal relationships established over the course of a career. So if you're in the army and have coins from the Air Force and your collection, it shows that you've collaborated across military branches, which can be really hard to do. The coins are physical proof of hard-fought relationships.
这些硬币展示了在职业生涯中建立的所有职业和个人关系。所以，如果你在陆军，并且收藏中有来自空军的硬币，这就表明你曾跨军种进行过合作，而这在军队中往往很难做到。这些硬币是来之不易的关系的有形证明。
To me, the coins are full of interesting contradiction. They're a combination of gravitas and tradition, with levity and joy. Like my friend Ben, if he wanted, could go take that heirloom of his grandfather's time in World War Two and Vietnam and go win a beer with it. You might not do those two things with the same coin. Some people might, but that's just one of the lovely contradictions that you find all over military life. In a world as regulated and rigorous as that of the United States military, the coins have this fluid quality about them. They're different coin check rules for different branches,
对我来说，这些硬币充满了有趣的矛盾。它们将庄重严肃与传统，和轻松愉快完美结合。就像我的朋友本，如果他愿意，他可以拿着他祖父在二战和越南时期留下的那件传家宝去赢一杯啤酒。你可能不会用同一枚硬币去做这两件截然不同的事。有些人可能会，但这正是你在整个军旅生活中随处可见的迷人矛盾之一。在像美国军队这样规整严苛的世界里，硬币却具有这种流动性。不同军种有不同的查验硬币规则，
the coin's use and popularity varies. The history doesn't have a set telling, the design doesn't have set rules. There is obviously a very regimented, very structured, very rule bound aspect to the military, but challenge coins and a lot of other things that are routine parts of daily military life mitigate that structure. Challenge coins are a reminder of the human elements of the massive U.S. military, a reminder that some servicemen constantly carry. I've been coinchecked at airports, been coinchecked at trade shows, I've been coinchecked at airports. I've been coinchecked at trade shows. I've been coinchecked everywhere.
硬币的用途和受欢迎程度也各不相同。历史没有固定的说法，设计也没有成文的规则。军队显然有着非常刻板、高度结构化、充满规则约束的一面，但挑战币以及日常军事生活中许多其他的常规事物，却弱化了这种结构感。挑战币提醒人们庞大的美国军队中充满人性的一面，这是某些军人时刻随身携带的提醒。我在机场被查验过硬币，在贸易展会上被查验过硬币，我在机场被查验过。我在贸易展会上被查验过。我到处都被人查验过硬币。
Now my, now my home's off limits. Don't be like crawling up my balcony at 3 a.m. to do a coin check on me on my property. But you catching outside of my property, and you know, game on. There's no way I'm climbing up on that dude's balcony at 3 a. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffleman with Katie Mingle, Sam Reanspan and me Roman Mars, special thanks to Ben Klas for waking up so early.
现在我的家是禁区。别像个爬虫似地在凌晨3点爬上我的阳台，在我私有财产上对进行硬币查验。但如果你在我的财产外面抓到我，你知道的，游戏就开始了。我才不会爬上那家伙的阳台呢。本周的《99% Invisible》由埃弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，合作者包括凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）、萨姆·里安斯潘（Sam Reanspan）以及我罗曼·马尔斯，特别感谢本·克拉斯（Ben Klas）起得这么早。
We are a project of 91.7KALW San Francisco and produced out of the offices of Arxelin, in architecture and interiors firm, in beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. Now, before we go, this is not an advertisement. I just want to tell you about something our pals at Radio Lab have been making over the last few months. It's a very cool experiment and if you haven't been Austin, you're headed there for a South by Southwest or if you live there, you should check it out. Radio Lab has made a story that you can only hear with a GPS-tiggered audio iPhone app
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个节目，制作地点位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的建筑和室内设计公司 Arxelin 的办公室。好了，在离开之前，这不是广告。我只想跟你们聊聊我们的好朋友 Radio Lab 过去几个月一直在制作的东西。这是一个非常酷的实验，如果你还没去过奥斯汀，或者你要去那里参加西南偏南（South by Southwest）音乐节，或者你住在那里，你应该去看看。Radio Lab 制作了一个故事，你只能通过一个由 GPS 触发的音频 iPhone 应用才能听到，
called Detour. The reason I specifically wanted to mention it is because a few weeks back, every did a story about Austin's moonlight towers and one of the stories that haunts the origin of the towers is the legend of the servant girl annihilator. And that's a lot of what Radio Laps Austin's story is about. The writer O Henry was living in Austin back then in 1885. He wrote this one letter I'll never forget.
名为 Detour（绕道）。我特别想提它的原因是因为几周前，埃弗里做了一个关于奥斯汀月光塔（moonlight towers）的故事，而萦绕在月光塔起源背后的故事之一就是“侍女杀手”（servant girl annihilator）的传说。Radio Lab 的奥斯汀故事很大一部分就是关于这个的。作家 O·亨利（O. Henry）当时就住在奥斯汀，那是 1885 年。他写过这样一封信，我永远不会忘记。
He said, town is fearfully dull except for the frequent raids of the servant girl and eye-lators who make things lively during the dead hours of the night. The murders all happened during this big moment of change in Austin's history and it really shook Austin. When the servant girl and eye-lator showed up in Austin we never heard of a serial killer. Nobody had. This was way before Jeff Redommer, before Son of Sam, even before Jack the Ripper. So if you want this totally immersive GPS triggered guided prequel to the Moonlight Tower story, Radio Lab has done it. And going on a tour with Radio Lab is literally the best thing you can do in Austin during South by Southwest.
他说：“这个小镇无聊得可怕，除了频繁出没的侍女杀手，他们在夜深人静时把这里搅得天翻地覆。”这些谋杀案都发生在奥斯汀历史上的这个重大变革时期，它确实震撼了奥斯汀。当侍女杀手出现在奥斯汀时，我们从未听说过连环杀手。谁也没听说过。这远在杰夫·雷多默（Jeff Redommer）之前，在山姆之子（Son of Sam）之前，甚至在开膛手杰克（Jack the Ripper）之前。所以，如果你想要这个完全身临其境、由 GPS 触发的月光塔故事的导游前传，Radio Lab 已经做到了。在西南偏南期间，跟着 Radio Lab 去参观绝对是你在奥斯汀能做的最棒的事。
I've been there many times, so I just thought that if you're already there or you're going to be there for the conference, download the DTore app and load the tour that's called the year that broke Austin. It's totally free and you're totally gonna dig it. We are a member of Radio Topia from PRX. If you subscribe to all the shows in Radio Topia, tweet at me at Roman Mars and say, I'm a Radio Topian and I'll retweet that, and I'll fave star it, and I'll praise your good taste. You can subscribe to them all at radiotopia.fm.
我去过那里很多次，所以我觉得如果你已经在那儿了，或者你要去参加会议，下载 Detour 应用并加载名为《打破奥斯汀的那一年》（The Year That Broke Austin）的导览。它完全免费，你绝对会喜欢的。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员。如果你订阅了 Radiotopia 的所有节目，请在推特 @ 我 @Roman Mars，说“我是 Radiotopia 的一员”，我会转发它，给它点赞，并赞赏你的好品味。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 订阅所有这些节目。
If you want to see pictures of challenge points, you got a lot of them at 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想看挑战币的照片，你可以在 99pi.org 上找到很多。这个剧集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。